welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and we have a
huge report dropping today in regards to
Loki according to super scooper Daniel
Richman the upcoming Disney Plus show
will be introducing Kang the Conqueror
into the MCU whilst this release was
held behind his patreon movie news
outlet full circle cinema later posted
this on the website if it's true it
looks like big things are gonna be
happening in the Marvel Universe going
ahead and well backwards which I'll go
into in just a bit before we get into
that I just wanna let you know we're
giving away a free copy of the nfinity
saga boxer on blu-ray and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure you
subscribe for the channel and leave your
thoughts on the report in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th March in
the cell be shipped out from the enter
baguettes the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part anyway the
report itself says that Loki is going to
be introducing kang the conqueror into
the MCU from the recent Super Bowl
trailer we know that Tom Hiddleston's
Loki will be captured by the TBA aka the
time variance Authority this mystical
agency deals with matters of the
multiverse and stops timelines from
spiraling out of control Kang has been
known to time travel from time to time
and this scoop lines up with another one
recently posted by Mikey Sutton within
the last couple of months certain did
say that Marvel was discussing making
Kang the main villain of the upcoming
fifth Avengers film certain stated that
the studio wished to dive deeper into
the time-travel aesthetic that was
introduced in endgame Mikey said that
though Doctor Doom and Galactus were
planned to be coming down the line
Marvel were going to use Kang in the
meantime to keep the universe ticking
over whether this is true or not remains
to be seen but in certain rapport he
said that Kang's threat will unite the
Avengers and Fantastic Four the article
said the film will feature half of the
two teams traveling to the year 2099
whilst the other half will wind up stuck
in the Old West meeting classic western
heroes like to gunkid
as for Loki himself the Disney Plus show
is said to take the god of mischief on a
time-travel journey in which he tries to
change various events in the MCS history
this throws him to blows with the TBA
and he is then captured and we also come
across
hang in a similar predicament Kang was
first introduced in the Fantastic Four
issue 19 all the way back in 1963 and is
debut itself featured the character
going back to ancient Egypt to try and
attempt to change the past before
becoming Kang he was Nathaniel Richards
a 31st century scholar that was actually
thought to be a descendant of Reed
Richards himself he tried to put
apocalypse as his heir but his rule was
cut short when he was defeated by the
Fantastic Four who had also been
displaced through time can travel back
to the future I met dr. doom we also
believed to be his ancestor the
character then designed his armor
similar to doom and well as they say the
rest is history or rather the future
look good so a lot of time you why me
Webley wobbly stuff he is known as the
Conqueror because he travels through
time attempting to conquer all tons of
versions of khang have appeared over the
years including iron lad who was
actually an adolescent version of the
antagonist iron lad himself travelled
through time to help serve the young
Avengers and as we know Marvel is
planning to do this so it does make a
lot of sense that Kang may be making his
debut soon I actually love to see
Nathaniel introduced in Loki and for the
events of the show to meld him into his
alter-ego and the name that we've come
to know advance of the comics will know
that Kang is a big threat and he could
definitely fill the void left by Thanos
quite easily the fact that he can
time-travel to will also negate the plan
from endgame as he will be able to
combat the strategy that the Avengers
used in that to save the universe he
definitely seems like the correct
villain Thailand up next due to the way
that the series has gone so far and he's
an amazing bad guy the leak did not
reveal how it was that the character
would be introduced into the storyline
but there's definitely enough evidence
to tie the two things together overall
I'm quite excited for this and I have
had reports on this in the past but was
never quite sure until we saw the TBA
badge which in my mind adds a lot more
weight to it I guess we'll find out when
Loki debuts on Disney Plus at the star
of 2021
but I'm very hyped with the news
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the report and if you believe it and
what you'd hope to see in the show
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out a
recent video in which we discussed some
of the insane details that you missed an
event is endgame I guarantee there's
some in there that you haven't noticed
before and if you want to support the
channel from its letters 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest some video topics
and breakdowns we massively appreciate
it and it goes a long way to helping
videos like this get made gonna come
chat to us after the show either follow
us at definition whitey or click the
discord link in the description below
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with heavy spoilers and hopefully
we see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
you